yo what's happening so you're here
because you want to see how we are about
to spend half a million bucks over the
next few months to launch our media
company well this is the video of how
we're going to do that but just scroll
down if you'll want to watch this and
read the article it has a lot of the
same information so last April my
co-founder John and I through this
conference called hustle time the idea
was to get 600 people in the room and
about 15 founders who could teach and
explain how they start and grew a
company even though they didn't know how
to code at all John and I had started a
company in the past even though we don't
know how to code so we thought that this
was kind of an interesting topic to
address most conferences are actually
super lame they seem like one of those
things where it's really forced awkward
networking really bad coffee and just a
bad bad bad time and the worst part is
is that a lot of these events cost
thousands of dollars to go to and no one
actually really wants to be there
everyone even leaves early so husk on
actually went really well we launched a
website in late January and eighty four
days later on April 24th the event
happened in that time we ended up
selling about six hundred tickets made
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
revenue and had folks fly in from all
over the world to promote the event
leading up to it we actually created
content every single week these were
mostly infographics or articles but they
would dive really really deep into how
either we did something like found our
speakers or how the founders who were
speaking how they accomplished whatever
they were speaking about afterwards we
sent a survey to all the attendees to
figure out what they loved but they
hated just so we can kind of figure out
how to make this better for next year so
the feedback was pretty good but one
thing that shocked us was that people
said that they didn't come because they
wanted to hear business tactics and
starting and growing a company but they
actually came because they wanted to
hear stories from these founders that
was pretty shocking because we had spent
12 weeks working on this big event on a
very specific topic it turns out people
didn't even come because of that reason
so we set out just to create a big event
but we ended up making a full-fledged
media company because of the content we
created beforehand it worked because
most content floating around our
Facebook page is a horrible mix should
be clickbait listicles on BuzzFeed or
upworthy
or just completely shallow and
meaningless articles that treat sort of
readers like a bunch of morons but with
the content recreated leading up to the
conference and even the talk themselves
we realized that we accidentally filled
this huge void we knew our readers were
intelligent and wanted real in-depth
relatable stories of people living epic
lives but then one of the stories to
have a lot more personality than just a
lifeless Wall Street Journal article as
we build out this company we're gonna be
giving tons of updates so you're gonna
be able to see what's working and what
isn't she'll either be able to watch
this go broke and starve or if it does
work pulling a McDuck and swimming in
pools of money so here's what we're
about to do we've got about five hundred
thousand dollars in the bank from
investors and from our profits from the
oil our last conference we're gonna
spend all of it over the course of a
year to build off this content company
and media startups here's how it's gonna
work we're gonna pick a theme a month
and then each week we're gonna dive deep
on a very specific story within that
theme I guess it's kind of like a this
American Life episode but hold over for
weeks instead of one hour so that's why
we're launching the hustle if you're
into this and you're kind of sick of
reading all this prep content all over
there that's floating around on your
Facebook feed just enter your email in
the box below and if you really really
really like us go ahead and share this
on your Facebook wall pulling a McDuck
and someone to pit some money pools of
money is it mutt McDuck screwed mix
screw or wait what a son or whatever
anyway rich doc Disney Scrooge McDuck
okay